Thanks to our friends at Wizards of
the Coast, we have a
United Dominaria bundle to open.  So,
without further ado, let's open.  The
giant die.  The terrain with
alternative art of Herd Migration.    A
few more plots of land.  Some
rule cards.  And of course, eight
collection boosters.  Alright, let's get to the
boosters.  Okay, first of eight.  Let's
begin.
Arcane Isle, fight below,
fused monstrosity, blessing of
battle fury, coalition,
war brute, furious roar, cutting celestial knight
, shatter terror,
striking tail, Aaron, benalite ruin, beautiful
square of heroes, strengthen the
coalition like foil.  First package,
very cool.  We're already on the second
of eight.  Let's go.  Arcane, swamp,
Jace's fiery tornado, prophecy of
shadows, shatter bones,
male aeronaut avizoa, slimefoot research,
electrostatic infantry.  Najali, the
storm runner.  Knight of the
Fury of Tory D'Avenant.  Urg, offspring of
Turg.  Oops.  And assemble the Titans for the
ramp and a foil citizen prison.
Very good.  Very good, third out of eight.
Let's open.  Beautiful stained glass art card
.  I think this is the first one I've
picked up.  That's really cool.  Mountain.
Connected to the Benalite faith, wanderer,
lightning strike, Jace,
fiery negotiator.  The Treaty of Weatherseed,
Resolute Reinforcements, Breed.  But is it
Braid?  No, bad.  Bad.  Recruits
from Averna.  Oh, cool.  A nefarious battle mage
.  Is that the art card we
got too?  We, we took it
.  Captain Nefarious Battle Mage.
Is this one of the "No, it isn't" ones.
Zahid, Ojen, Cila of Ifnir.  Wow,
what is that?  Ilharg, the Devastating Boar
.  Wow, that's three stained-glass windows.  Oh, cool.
Jaya, the Fiery Negotiator.  And we pulled
a badger out of the foil swamp.
Amazing package.  Stained glass cards, stained
glass art, and a Jaya.  Too much.  We're already on
the fourth of eight.  Let's go.  Oh,
gosh.  Okay, it looks like we have a
special card.  Art, signed, gilded.
Montanha, this promises to be a good
package.  Enslaved by the abyss,
extinguishing the light,
opportune interference, automatic librarian,
Tolarian terror, limiting the third
way, relic of legends.  I think this
is my first one of these.  Wrath,
ship's steward, bortuk,
bone rattle, gix cruelty, and a
foil academy law master with a card from the
list sinking to attack enoma.  Wow.
What a package.  Alright, let's start
with the fifth of eight packages.  Great,
I love this letter.  Jodah, the Unifier.
Incredible stained glass art.  Beautiful stained
glass landscape.  Radiant Forest.  Raise the
Shield.  Aggressive Sabotage.  Bailoth, the
Breaker of Lines.  Yavimaya.
Icatian Herald.  Queen Alela, Alena, Aleno of
Rubruck.  The Climate Seed Treaty
.  Profaner Vronvoldalian.
Beautiful stained glass window.  Uh, is this one of the
commander's letters?  No, it isn't.  Rulik
Mons, War Chief.  Great,
we got a Squee, Dubious Monarch.
And a Marwyn, Scout of Marwyn.  Nice
package.  Okay, moving on to the sixth of
eight packages.  Let's go.  Oh, cool.
Ivy, Spell Thief, stained glass art card
, very cool.  Terrain,
Prophecy of Shadows, Bone Shards,
oops.  In Captivity in the Well,
Loon Pearl's Battle Hymn, Twin Inferno
, Bizarro, Nishoba the Brawler, adorable
Phoenix Chick, Rona, folks, and
we got a Temporary Blockade
as a rare and a beautiful Walking Bulwark
as a foil.  Incredible.  Reaching
the last packages, seventh of eight.
Let's go.  Mountain,
Maginot Sentinel, Man-o'-War of Kerr Salvation
, Gaia's Power, Protect the
Negotiators, Torga, Coalition Sky Knight
, Battle Wing Mystic
, Bird.  Let's call it
Bird.  Danitha Capashen, all in
stained glass, very good.  Kolios Cave
for the rare and we have a metallic Thurg Spore
.  I love this letter.  Another
brilliant package.  Alright, time for the
last package, eight out of eight.  Let's
go.
Ooh, very cool, right?  Only one
stained-glass plot so far.
Idyllic Seaside, Pixie Illusionist,
Griffin Protector, Brave,
Righteous Return, Monstrous War Leech
, Hero's Legacy,
Joint Exploration, Joint Forces.  We have a
nail in the stained glass window.  Legal.  Master of the
Runic Belt Strings for the rare.  And
a Planex Encanviano for the metallic finish.
Alright, so this is our takeout
from the package box.  We managed to get 10
rare items in eight packs.  We obtained
several stained glass letters.  Uh,
obviously, the best card is Nissa,
a very good mythic.  Once again,
many thanks to Wizards of the Coast
for sending this.  I hope you
enjoyed the United Dominaria collection
.  Thanks for watching, and I'll see
you next time.